[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spec TV and
broadcast on the 20th of July I'm John
Connolly The Spectators news editor and
your host this week
it's the start of the summer recess and
Rishi sunax conservatives are still down
20 points in the polls how bad can
things get for the piano I'll speak to
Katie balls the Magazine's cover story
this week is the great motorist
Rebellion a London's ultra low emission
Zone Steve Carr wants to expand it to
the furthest reaches of outer London but
a motorist being pushed too far I'll
speak to Lionel Shriver and Robert
Hardman
Douglas Murray writes his column this
week about Canada's creeping euthanasia
laws which will soon allow those with
mental illnesses to legally take their
own lives he'll be on the show
is Rhonda Sanders's campaign to beat
Donald Trump in free fall Freddie gray
joins me to discuss this answer's
flailing run from the Republican
nomination and finally what makes a real
sports fan and why do some fans turn
away when Sports gets to tense I'll
speak to Mark Mason
before we get going please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel spectator TV is
picking up thousands of new subscribers
every week and you should be one of them
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss an episode
first up how bad could things get for
the Tories I'm joined Now by political
editor Katie balls
Katie thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you mentioned at the beginning of
your column this week that Richie sunac
is going into the summer holidays with
well not in a great position compared to
was when he started his Premiership so
you can tell us a bit about that and the
promise he's facing right now yes it
feels so a little bit Groundhog Day at
the moment for the Tory party in the
sense that he is going into the long
summer recess Parliament finishing this
week A Faculty where he was in the polls
at the start of the year which is 20
points behind and I think there are
points um I think there's particular
optimism in that spring period And I
think that we had a peace and spectator
written by myself in a springtime for
Rishi and and the sense of um hope and
you could see the poll Gap closing now
since the local elections I think
there's been a sense of drift and lots
of problems free by-elections this week
for speaking just before them of course
um but two or three sparked by Tory
Psycho Drama regarding Boris Johnson's
resignation honors list do you also have
um the economy which is not going to
plan in terms of riches you know uh
efforts or what he expected to happen on
board touring costs even though this
week with inflation there's signs of
hints of positivity and therefore you'll
just see into a sense where I think
things do feel pretty and doom Laden for
the Tory party at the moment and these
free by-elections if as expectedly uh
lose all three will just add to this
sense that um it's gonna be really
really difficult to turn around so
Richard sula's answer to all of this so
far and in fact he's answered to almost
every single question has been to sort
of reiterate his five priorities I mean
how's that going do you think that
strategy is going to start to wear thin
a bit after a while so number 10 hate
the word reset
um because I think they think that often
this is what people do when they panic
and I think we can just think about you
know recent uh Prime Ministers whenever
there's a big speech try and change the
mood often this feature is disappointing
everyone said is is that it so I don't
think you're going to see a purpose
photo we're changing plans
um if anything
um what you're hearing from those
working clothes to the Prime Minister
there's a doubling down on the five
priorities and I think they see that
inflation a bit uh like uh Cameron and
Osborne saw the deficit so you only get
to do things after by in that case
reducing the deficit but here
um having inflation go down to a level
where all of a sudden more more options
are in play when it comes to tax cuts
and so forth so I think we're going to
keep hearing about the five priorities
but at the same time there will be a
change of Gears so I think Autumn has
seen as a point where not an official
reset but was always a point that uh
annual Party Conference where Richard
will try and lay out a probably a wider
Vision because at the moment the five
priorities are effectively and he
addressed Tory MPS this week and it's
almost as though I think montreum who
said you know you look behind the
wallpaper you found five cracks and now
you're working it had to cover them
wallpaper again and so it's almost a
damage limitation exercise because these
are big problems and what Tory MPS want
is a it's a wider Vision or something
offering a bit more hope going into an
election year he also had The King's
Speech which will be a chance for
receiving Shrine uh not just say what he
hopes to do by the end of the past
Parliament but also give a sense of what
he would do if he somehow was still in
power and after the next election and I
think there's also talk of a Cavett
reshuffle
um which would also play in a sense but
I think
um trying to move things off which from
what's been a pretty tricky I think six
weeks yeah on the on the reshuffle point
there's been persistent rumors about
this what are kind of the benefits and
costs that number 10 is thinking if they
do have a reshuffle so I think both
kirst armor and Richard sudak are under
pressure from rest of back benches and
some common problems here to shake up
their front bench teams and they're
under particular pressure in terms of uh
for themselves what do they want to say
if they are going to have a pre-election
reshuffle because we saw had David
Cameron in 2014 used a pre-election
reshuffle to really work out what he
wanted to focus on his message to voters
and it was that point it's quite
ruthless so Michael Gove who had
ultimately performed the education
reforms that David Cameron had wanted
had made too many enemies in the process
so he was moved to backroom role Nikki
Morgan was moved out she was seen as
someone who was more into Israel seen as
someone who was more friendly on their
Airwaves and would do better and then
you also hadn't um you know the get rid
of the green crap message from Linton
Crosby and that affected to uh he was in
the front bench so this is a chance to
put your best foot forward so to speak
and I think one thing to look out for is
um at the moment I think there is a bit
of a frustration that when it comes to
the media appearances you don't always
have ministers coming out to bat for the
government now
part of that is because there has been a
media strategy number 10 to slow down
news you often told uh you know by
figures in government we try to get you
off the sugar highs if um the
journalists are the problem for covering
psychodrama too much so I would argue
last year the Tories gave journalists
plenty to work with and that but there
has been the sense of trying to slow the
news cycle down that doesn't really work
going into an election year because you
want to be getting your message out so I
think you're going to see amongst those
promoted people you are willing to take
those tricky slots since then there's an
unquestion time getting lots of uh
criticism potentially heckles
um and also perhaps we'll get someone uh
if you think about 2015 Michael Fallon
defense secretary when he uh penned a
piece and then gave an interview where
he effectively said you can't trust EDM
with abandoned Trident and because he
might you know stab the UK in the back
like he did his brother David which at
the time I think even Tories were saying
whoa that's a bit too personal but he
reasoned it out it was a part of a strat
G and obviously the Tories went on to
win so who is going to be the rishi's
Michael Fallon before we go we should
probably move to labor as well because
they've not had the easiest week either
there's been a route over the two-child
benefit cap
um was was kissed armor thinking with
this route because it's obviously
something that's going to settled back
to this and his and his own MPS so I
think it's really interesting right this
week in the sense that one of the things
I say in the column is it does feel as
though Victoria's in a bit of a
stalemate when you look at the polls but
yet the political landscape is changing
as the year goes on because I think
Labor's plans are coming under a lot
more scrutiny they're also having to
make decisions the closer they get to
power set out what they would do and
that's only going to going to increase
and as we get closer to an election and
the election year and the benefits were
out I think has taken some in labor by
surprise this week because
kissed um along with most of his shadow
cabinet I've called the two-child
benefit cat pretty abhorrent and talked
about getting rid of it
um you had uh that John and ashra's
predecessor as Shadow work compension
secretary said at Labor conference a few
years ago that they would accept that
was when kissed arm as a leader so it
was Labor policy there have been hints
that they were rolling back on that so I
think his starmer and a q a about you
know just over a week ago suggested that
the policy was not to actually scrap it
and and there was little reaction then
he goes on a Sunday Morning Show and
there were raccoonsbergs and he is asked
about there and he says that policy is
not changing if you have more than two
children at the moment you don't get
benefits would that change under a labor
government we're not changing that
policy we're not changing the two child
policy benefits and there's outrage in
terms of the labor party and often we
hear that actually Kings Dominos a
strategic genius for picking a fight
with the left of his party which is seen
over Jeremy corbyn and I think there is
obviously that has helped kisama to show
he is different than Jeremy corbyn and
despite of course serving in his shadow
cabinet and playing into their
connection during the leadership contest
um but I think here it's not just the
left of the party that's pretty appalled
that this um cat could say
um it's also MPS across the party and I
think it's a Jammer rule if MPS across
the party in the different tribes uh all
very unhappy and making that known this
week quite a fiery weekly meeting of the
Parliamentary party that's a bad place
for a leader to be because it raises
questions about whether he can really
hold the line and depending on what size
majority received if he was in
government and it all comes back to
fiscal responsibility ultimately uh
Rachel Reeves and kirstana think that
it's more important to show they're not
going to spend in in a way which the
Tories can attack as making the economy
worse but I think here
um this has not been you know a clear
message and actually it's causing
because Donald quite a lot of problems
in terms of his own brilliant thank you
Katie and we'll be showing a special
episode of the view from 22 tomorrow
after the by-election results
the cover piece this week's magazine is
about ulas the daily charge leveled on
londoners for driving cars made before
2005. it's really the best way to
improve air quality in the capital and
combat climate change I'm joined Now by
a columnist Lionel Shriver and the Daily
Mail is Robert Hardman
Robert Lionel thank you for joining us
on spectator TV now Robert started off
couldn't um can you tell us a bit about
Sadiq Khan's Oola's scheme how it works
and and how it's been changing to affect
places like Oxbridge
well uh I mean I yes it's it's now
entering its third phase it started out
uh as a charge on uh it's essentially
boils down to what sort of uh diesel
you're driving but if you've got a car
that predates 2015
um then you are not us compliance stands
for ultra low emissions though
it began imposed in central London where
people were perfectly used to things
like the congestion charge where there
are plenty of buses uh tubes and it
generally just sort of arrived then it
was extended in 2021 to inside the north
side circular Zone that caused a bit of
a a harump because
um people there are more used to driving
around but it generally it landed people
got on with it what's happening now is
as of next month it extends to really
out to the M25 it's the entire
um footprint of greater London taking in
millions of people and I think the
mayor's got it in his mind that you know
people just sort of get on with it as
they have done with previous impositions
but I think that's to completely misread
the nature of life in outer London we're
talking metrolab we're talking suburbs
we're talking places that sort of run
into the home counties um why you don't
see people uh riding long bike Lanes
like you do in the center of town it's
just it's a different culture people
need their cars and a lot of them are
pre-2015 uh these cars but I think
there's a more fundamental Point here
and I think I found this when I was out
on the stomp in Uxbridge and South
ruislip the other day talking to people
it sort of it's really emblematic of a
misunderstanding between either London
and out of London these are people who
feel very overlooked there's not much of
a local identity if you live in
Berkshire or you live in I don't know in
Vanessa or whatever
um you know you've got a sort of clear
sense you've got your kind of local
paper a local radio station you feel you
know who you are if you live in places
like that yes source of regarded as a
Londoner except London's not listening
to you and the main difference in those
areas is that to get around these
boroughs they've got very good
Communications with Central London you
get on uh the Metropolitan line the
Piccadilly line I know the Elizabeth
line be in central London in no time but
if you want to move around the borough
you want to go north south you want to
go two miles down the road it's almost
impossible without a car there are no
cycle Lanes you get run over by a lorry
uh there's no tube the buses are rubbish
you need your car and now sadiq's gonna
charge you 12 pounds 50 a day from next
month for the privilege of putting it in
gear and Lionel you're a cyclist so
you're not actually gonna be affected by
you as that much personally but you're
quite against the scheme can you can you
tell us why
well I I feel self-conscious and even a
little embarrassed because uh the many
of these anti-car measures are being
enacted in effectively my name uh it's
supposed to make it easier for uh
alternative transportation which I take
almost exclusively so I should be
pleased and of course there's a lot of
antagonism emotionally as well as
logistically between motorists and
cyclists even more than pedestrians but
uh I am not pleased I do not want people
to put to Great expense and
inconvenience on my behalf and I find a
lot of or changes to how one gets around
in my immediate neighborhood uh in
London uh they don't really make my life
better and they make other people's
lives a whole lot worse a good example
is uh this weird thing in Southwick they
start inputting these giant flower pots
in the middle of one of the lanes of a
two-lane you know a two-way street and
they reduce it to one lane now on my
bike I can get through on the other side
that's the idea but you have
ways of traffic coming
at each other like this and it's
deliberate it's it's it's impractical on
purpose it's supposed to make it bloody
impossible
and
um you know I'm I know it's odd but I've
become much more sympathetic with the
motorists uh I don't need this this is
not making my wife any better and it's
making their lives worse and I don't see
how it's improving things
environmentally and in terms of the um
the who has uh okay fine strictly
speaking it's not going to hit me out of
pocket because of my immediate needs
going to the supermarket but I use
Tradesmen I have a house it's constantly
falling apart because that's what houses
do and most of the Tradesmen that I use
are in outer London because they can't
afford to be an inner London so they
have to travel to me and ultimately they
would have to to transfer the cost of
coming to my house to my bill
so it actually affects a lot more people
than the people it does immediately and
I also I don't want to see them put out
of business
um and and this is going to put a lot of
people out of business yeah I mean that
really came through in your piece from
Oaks Bridge Robert when you're talking
to trades people and businesses I mean
can you tell us a little bit about how
they're going to be affected by the
scheme being expanded there
yeah they definitely feel this is this
is anti-business because uh a lot of um
small businesses were encouraged I spoke
to one business who were positively
encouraged by the government by the car
dealership yeah you've got to go diesel
this is back in 2012 they bought uh up
they're that their big investment
um that they still use now of course are
going to be punished for it and the
point they make
um is it's not just affecting those
Tradesmen who had to drive in and out if
you're running a business in those
peripheral areas what you're effectively
doing is alienating 50 of your potential
clientele because as this carpet
showroom I went to see in in ruislip the
the lady there said look you know for
years people people will drive in and
they'll have a look at carpets and
they'll make a decision now they're not
going to come to me if they come from
outside the zone and Uxbridge is right
on the on on the edge people outside the
zone are going to come into the zone so
you're you'll automatically alienating
those sort of people who will gravitate
outwards I went to a hostings it was
fascinating actually there were 11
candidates said that the two main ones
weren't
um for various reasons
but everybody even the greens even the
climate party uh were arguing against
the way that um Khan mayor Khan is
imposing this for all the climate party
uh made a I've had a sensible suggestion
which is what you know maybe you start
off with a very small uh penalty charge
sort of a pound or two per day and then
gradually incrementally work it as cars
as as old Vehicles work their way out of
the system it's it's incredibly
unpopular I mean the the the labor
position is that this is just a sort of
Tory scaremongering tactic no one really
cares about who lets everybody wants
clean air uh but but almost every
candidate as I say there are two
candidates standing simply on a no
useless ticket uh and and and and there
really is a sense that it's it's it's
picking on on small people uh and and it
goes far beyond uh just those who might
have a car that's not compliant and even
those people who've now gone and bought
a car that is but are extremely cross
because they've had to go and spend
thousands of buyers tens of batteries in
many cases on on a car they didn't need
so I I think I I don't know whether it's
going to be enough to to win the bowl
allow the Tories to hang on enough but
it's certainly uh going to cost labor uh
a lot of votes do you think City Khan
has underestimated the anger against it
as well then
yes I think he's I think he's made the
mistake of of judging out to London by
the standards of inner and Islamic
saying you know yes if you ride a bike
around I mean if you I mean I live in in
the sort of middle lands if you like in
the sort of Shepherd's bush area a lot
of people ride bikes but still a lot of
people dry branding cars but I think you
know the the you couldn't jump on a tube
you can jump on a bus there are ways
around it
um but I as I said I was in in the
beyond the north side circulates in in
the outer suburbs
um people you know every if there's a
car on every driveway it's it's sort of
part of life it's it is a sort of I mean
I I said in my piece on this in the mail
at the weekend I mean you know culturals
are just about you know gender and
Empire I mean there is a sort of sense
that the motorist out in these these
suburbs yeah they do I think feel
genuinely they're being marginalized and
I I think this could be a a a much uh
more significant
um polarization uh than simply people
who happen to bought a diesel car
pre-2015. oh and you mentioned in your
piece about this Lionel it's very
interesting the fact that you know Sadiq
Khan has Justified this policy on
environmental grounds in particularly
air quality but it doesn't the evidence
doesn't really seem to back that okay
can you tell us a bit about that it
doesn't add up and in fact um you
Ross Clark's excellent cover piece on
this issue he documents that the figures
that the mayor has commissioned are
fixed and don't stand up and when you
analyze the results of uh congestion
charging originally that he has used to
just the expansion of the
Ula Zone
um the amount of reduction in um
air pollution is at best three percent
and uh in terms of particulates
it's actually a little bit worse
um so it seems uh transparently
disingenuous that this is really about
money rates because ever since the
pandemic uh Transport for London has
been running in the red they they
desperately need more money and that's
what an awful lot of this anti-car stuff
is about because councils as well
as Ross mentions have
um you know they're getting less money
from central government so if they need
they need Dosh and uh and they are
reaming the motorists as as viciously as
they know how
and you know you add that to a cost of
living crisis and the highest taxes in
70 years and
you know you you just feel persecuted
and I think quite just Lisa and I think
this is a huge political mistake uh
Brits are pretty
tolerant they take a lot of abuse far
more than most nationalities certainly
not like the French
um but
um
you can you can push even a Brit see it
far well I was going to say rather I
mean we've got Net Zero on the horizon
as well you'd sort of think we're going
to start seeing more more and more of
these kind of policies that are going to
rub up against people's lives we're
gonna get you know certain types of car
engine bans coming up do you think we're
going to see a bit of backlash to it a
bit of heavy backlash to it at some
points
well I was intrigued in on the on the
by-election trial that one of the
candidates actually
um I won't say which one but um
confessed to me that um he goes around
removing you let's go well talk to me
about how he does it
um and even said that at one point he'd
been arrested but nothing had come of it
um I think this there is some yeah there
is a feeling of oh can push herself says
you push people so far
um I I several people in in Oxbridge
actually liken this to a sort of poll
tax moment the poll tax that many people
sales finally brought down Margaret
Thatcher in 1990 you know this could
actually be the way uh the the the way
in which labor managed to lose the next
mayoral election I mean it was
intriguing you know I I was there I'm
not a transport expert I I I'm not an
environment cross but I I commend Ross
Clark's excellent piece magazine I read
it
um it makes the point
um that so many of the stats in this are
just hopeful
um you know uh and and of course we want
clean air I mean that goes without
saying and and inner London has
different clean air issues too out of
London um but this isn't really gonna
make much difference so that the cleaner
side of things I think people see
through that now
um and and and they are going to get
angrier and I think it is he's sort of
going to lead to perhaps you know new
forms of of cell Disobedience people are
sitting out I mean just yesterday I
walked out of my front door and there
was a just stop oil protest coming down
the road holding up all the traffic
people are absolutely Furious from that
way to work five people in High vids uh
jackets as walking down the road very
slowly and occasionally stopping
um and and there are two sides to that
coin um and if people feel
um the the that that side it's a cleaner
just stop oil extension Rebellion uh uh
end of the spectrum if they feel that
they're able to get away with it well I
think they're gonna maybe push things
the other way and and so to the mayor I
just say be careful what you wish for
and a lot of you've you've said you're
in favor of uh camera vandalization when
it when it comes to less cameras can you
tell us why
well I think that dovetails with what I
was just talking about it very unbritish
um and I like it when the British start
acting unbritish
I mean they're so well behaved
um and
I I think it shows spunk
um I was a little anxious uh writing uh
admiringly of breaking the law in The
Spectator sure whether that might be
edited out
um but uh you know I
this is what I'm talking about you know
you push people so far and in a certain
point
they will strike back
um and I I'm afraid that we're going to
be looking at this across the board with
all these Net Zero uh
initiatives many of which are designed
to just get more money out of your
pocket
but most importantly
are not they're not thinking globally
they they are all cart before horse that
is you you you you designed the uh
system of Hell taste or not being
compliant with this that and the other
thing but you don't put together a world
of an alternative that is functional
so I mean you know the whole heating
thing is a good example of for half the
housing in the UK these uh the new
systems do not work they cannot be
fitted but still we have we have a wall
where you're not going to be able to get
gas boiler after a certain year so you
you this is the wrong order
you have to sort out the logistics first
and then you're going to get compliance
yes that means the ordinary work
ordinary wife is still
practical and still functional and is
still economical but none of this stuff
has been worked out
and what you're doing is just driving
your entire Society toward a dead end
well it's a very good point I have one
other thing I I think there it it's a
it's a more General point but uh
adopting this a one-size-fits all
um strategy just something like you know
it just doesn't work I mean another
recurring complaint I I came across and
not just on this by-election trial but
elsewhere
um is is that in in actual under you
know families on the whole some families
don't have cars as the mail will point
out but a lot of families have one car
and that one car is how they they meet
up with other families I mean I I spoke
to several people who've made the point
that you know mum and dad live just
outside the Zone their cars and
compliant they drive out to see them
this charge it's not just uh a sort of
nine to five charge it's 24 hours a day
every day of the year except Christmas
Day frankly you know there's some people
thinking well maybe maybe it'll just
sort of see the family on Christmas Day
and that's it because
um you know 12 pounds 50 again it's sort
of huge sum to to perhaps it's it's a
driver in in central London
um
it's it's added up day by day it's an
awful lot of money out in in Oxbridge
and South ruislip and and if it's seen
as a policy that makes it harder just to
see your loved one so you live a few
miles down the road and you have to
drive to see them because there's no bus
at the weekends and there's no tube uh
then I'm afraid that's that is gonna
have a an electoral and political
concept
brilliant thank you very much Robert
thank you Lytle
from next year Canada will expand as
assisted death laws so people with
mental illnesses can choose to end their
own lives in a spectator column this
week Douglas Murray wonders what lovely
liberal Canada is doing he joins me now
Douglas thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you imagine the magazine this week
about how Canada is expanding its
assisted dying laws and what sounds like
a pretty horrific way uh can you tell us
about it please
yes I mean long-term reads of the
magazine will now have written about
this in the magazine before there's an
incredibly complex uh and intense debate
about assisted dying and there are good
arguments on all sides
um but one of the points that I have
made repeatedly in the magazine in about
different countries in recent years is
the necessity of making sure that if you
are talking about assisted dying for the
uh the terminally ill who can have
nothing done to help them effectively a
sort of slightly earlier palliative care
um you've got to be extremely careful
that this doesn't expand and I wrote
some years ago having spoken to doctors
who did euthanasia in the Netherlands
and Belgium the the old slippery slope
argument we hear about and people
usually use as a dismissal they say oh
you're getting all slippery slope on us
I said well here is an ethical question
where the slope is really slippery uh it
was in Belgium again last year I wrote
about the case of the young woman who
was
um was killed by the state allowed to
die by the state phrase it as you will
because she had PTSD from surviving the
Brussels Airport attack in 2016 where
she saw many of her classmates she was
17 at the time blown up in front of her
the Belgian stage is far too civilized
of course to uh execute any of the men
involved in the Brussels Airport attack
but it did manage to put down one of the
victims of the attack because now being
chalked up as another victim this time
it's Canada that is that is on this
slope and gosh is it slippery in 2016 uh
the lovely liberal Canadian government
introduced what it called the medical
assistance in dying or made act and
again as in so many other Western
countries it was meant to be only for
people with terminal illness and that's
how it got through but through as if
it's incredibly strict
two years ago the Canadian government
expanded the law and two years ago it
was allowed to Encompass people who had
non-terminal conditions
so you can see where this is going
as of March next year this is going to
be expanded again and it will be allowed
to include medically assisted dying for
people whose sole underlying condition
is mental illness
now I suggest that anyone who isn't at
this point ethically concerned
isn't thinking deeply about this
and there's a specific case you
mentioned as well Douglas I think it's
Lisa poorly can you can you tell her a
bit about tell us a bit about her
yes she gave an interview recently she's
one of a number of people who've said
you know they're sort of looking forward
to next march the Canadian government
itself presents uh the development of
the new law as if it's a sort of
wonderful exciting new opportunity for
the Canadian public it it's pretty
dystopian if you think about it like
that a woman called Lisa pawley is one
of those who seems to be viewing it in
that light she's a 47 year old woman and
she's suffered from anorexia uh for most
of her life she's had you know it's very
debilitating eating disorder and
unfortunately for her
um unlike many young women who have it
she hasn't been able to shake it off
um she hasn't been able to get rid of it
she currently weighs I think six Stone
six pounds uh she uh is too weak to
carry groceries back from the shop she
says every day is Hell I'm so tired I'm
done I've tried everything I feel like
I've lived my life uh it was a quote she
gave and as I say in the piece of 47
year old who feels that they've lived
their life is a 47 year old in need of
help and I would submit that anorexia
which is an incredibly debilitating
condition as anyone knows who's either
had it themselves I had a family member
or a loved one who's had it knows that
it requires very very intense help love
support and much more
but the message given off by a society
that says actually we've got a cure for
anorexia it's medical assistance in
dying is a society that gives out one of
the worst messages possible to the
predominantly young women who suffer
from that condition
and like I say I think it would be
rightfully seen as abhorrent if you told
someone with anorexia that they assured
or they're right to think that they
should kill themselves but Canada seems
to be sort of sleet walking towards this
I mean you mentioned in your in your
first answer the fact that this is a
very liberal soft cuddly government do
you think that's linked to the fact that
they've just sort of lost their moral
compass on this
oh absolutely and you know to do
something truly atrocious you have to
wrap it up these days in the language of
compassion you can do almost anything
get away with almost anything in a
modern society if you talk about an
incompassionate term I give the example
at the beginning of the piece I open the
piece by talking about Martin amos's
1991 Masterpiece times Arrow it's it's a
novel where everything goes backwards
time goes backwards everything happens
in Reverse
um every daily action and uh it includes
as part of its its its narrative is the
Holocaust in reverse and I say is this
very it's very hard to say anything new
about the Holocaust but Martha name is
to manage it or have any new light on it
Martin's name is managers actually in
that novel
um when towards what is the end of the
Holocaust in the reverse which is of
course the beginning of the Holocaust as
it happened uh the bodies that they take
out of the oven and bring into life one
of the people who works in the the
Crematory it starts to worry that the
bodies that they're taking out of the
oven seem to be increasingly deformed
and the character in The Amos novel
starts to wonder whether it's worth
bringing these people to life at all
which is of course a reference to that
way in which and I'm not using the
Holocaust to say what Canada is doing is
about to lead to the murder of millions
of Jews or anything like that I'm saying
that it's a reminder of the fact that
such great atrocities from history can
start with things that people can nod
along in the name of compassion a lot of
eugenics went this way started this way
um a medically assisted eye assistance
to people with debilitating conditions
and much more the mentally ill and I say
that there's a particular corner of this
and I've pointed this out in the
magazine before I pointed this out when
Britain was considering new laws on this
much of the problem of this is the
Illusion in our day
uh between medical illness and mental
illness physical illness and mental
illness huge amount of work has been
done and again you might be in favor of
this or against it but huge amount of
work has been done by government by the
NHS by celebrities even Royals to talk
about the way in which medical the way
in which uh mental illness should be
regarded as being on a par with physical
illness once you get onto euthanasia
medically assisted diet as they call it
the getting kind of made
once you get onto that and you say
mental ill you have a society that says
mental illness and physical illness are
on a par then you allow people to find a
way on the state to be killed
effectively assisted to die because they
have a mental illness I give the example
in the piece this has already come up
this is not a um this is not a dystopian
uh fear-mongering last year a member of
the Canadian Armed Forces a veteran
called this veterans uh Veterans Affairs
Canada which is sort of veterans support
Association he was suffering from PTSD
so bear that in mind this is a this is a
young man who had been sent to War by
his country had presumably seen some of
the things you see in war war is always
unpleasant always uh traumatizing to
some extent to the people who
participate in it this man had been sent
out by his country he's now returned he
should be getting the best possible care
as all veterans should be when he called
Veterans Affairs Canada unprompted he it
was suggested by the person he spoke
with that perhaps he should try
euthanasia
now
PTSD is especially for it's been it's
somewhat over diagnosed in recent years
but PTSD for soldiers uh the veterans is
a very serious thing which needs very
serious again love care compassion and
treatment the idea that you would as a
society say we will send our soldiers
out to fight and kill and potentially
die for the country and if they find it
all too traumatic once they get home we
can kill them
this is not a dystopia this has already
started and all in the name of
compassion societies that do this will
among other things become far less
Justice the Netherlands of Belgium are
far less developed in palliative care
than Britain is and the doctors involved
for told me this because they have
euthanasia in those countries so a
country like Canada that believes that
that that medically assisted dying
euthanasia is a good response to trauma
to anorexia and much more will be a
society that that is less good at
treating people with those conditions in
the way in which they should be treated
because they will be offering death as
one of the options on the board of
treatments and you mentioned the piece
as well that you know and and as you're
saying that it takes a lot of effort and
a lot of States capacity to sort of help
some of these mental illness whilst
euthanasia is almost the cheap easy
option do you get the sentences of
almost like a
a financial incentive to push people
towards euthanasia now
well I don't know if there is at the
moment but there could well be at some
point one of the the moral issues that
has often come up with euthanasia even
for people with medical conditions that
are terminal is can we be sure that
loved ones aren't encouraging them to
this effectively to get a cash Bonanza
it seems unimaginable that anyone would
but human nature being what it is of
course some people will so there has
always been this kind of fear even with
the most clear-cut case that people in
favor of euthanasia can present which is
people with terminal illnesses uh who
are close to the to the end anyway
um of course uh it's it's not just
possible but likely the financial
incentives will start to step into this
they always do
um the Canadian government has had such
extraordinary overreach in recent years
in things like again as I've written
about before in the magazine the closure
of bank accounts of people who are
critics of it at home the um Corruption
of the Canadian media all these things
have been done in the name of compassion
and much more the Canadian government is
already pretty corrupted actually among
Western governments uh um and uh it
seems to be able to get away Trudeau
himself seems to be able to get away
with almost anything because he does it
in this dippy
um sort of floppy-haired floppish
language of compassion and love while
showing very little Compassion or love
for the people of his country and in
fact a sort of disdain for the average
person I have absolutely no faith in the
Canadian government to be fair in its
treatment of its citizenry if they have
any views that the Canadian government
doesn't disagree with the idea that the
choice of life or death could be in the
hands of the Canadian government gives
me the shudders again then this is a
government that believes it is too
Superior too morally pure to ever think
of executing for somebody for a cry such
as mass murder child rape or anything
else far too morally Superior like
Britain like all the EU countries we
think we've got beyond that we've got
Beyond public execution we've got Beyond
private executions executions in prisons
of prisoners with two two we're past
that we've developed
but we are or Canada is a society
able to allow and encourage indeed
people with
mental conditions like anorexia iptsd to
be effectively killed by the state I
don't think the state has that right
anywhere I I cannot see how a country
posing as a liberal democracy can go
down this route without criticism and
and finally Douglas I wonder what you
think about the lessons for Britain here
I mean as I say there's been a
long-running campaign for euthanasia in
the case of terminal illnesses do you
think it's possible to have that and
stop there or do you think once that
sort of Rubicon has been crossed of the
state taking a life then you're sort of
opening yourself up for a world of
Horrors
well I've had this argument on The
Spectator podcast before not least with
with Lord Faulkner who was one of the
people uh pushing the assisted dying act
in the House of Lords
um he was one of those who again he it's
all oh Douglas is getting all slippery
slope on us
um if I was Lord falcon or one of the
people in that campaign in the UK and I
know and has spoken with people involved
in that I respect the opinions of some
of them very very much but if I were
them I would look at what was happening
in Canada and think those Canadians have
mucked up our whole case you know the
whole way in which the the assisted
dying in Britain act would come in would
be if it was incredibly carefully
defined and Incredibly carefully policed
and it is already clear in my view from
the Netherlands and Belgium which are
not far away from us as Societies in any
uh ethical or geographical sense it's
already clear from there how slippery
this slope is and where Lord Falcon and
others say I would is getting all
slippery slope on us now I will say
again look at Canada look at what you
can do in Canada now in the name of
compassion look at the Canadian
government's websites the way in which
it presents next march as being this
wonderful new opportunity for Canadians
this really is something atrocious
happening in our own time and as the
editor of spectator phrase and Allison
has said to me a number of times and I
often quote it instead of just wrecking
through the past and looking at what
other people did and how astonishingly
awful it was also think of what is
happening in your own time that our
successors might think is equally awful
and look at in an equally despising
light try to work out what they are now
and try to stop them early I would
suggest that when it comes to medically
assisted dying in the west and the
slippery slope in these Ultra liberal
democracies it is just such a case thank
you very much Douglas
over the weekend Ronda santis fired a
dozen of his campaign staff the Florida
governor is around 30 points behind
Trump in the race for the Republican
nomination and thought his campaign
needed a reset in this week's magazine
our Deputy editor Freddie gray looks at
what's gone wrong for him
Freddie joins me now
Freddie thank you for joining us on
spectator TV great pleasure John you're
right this week about Rhonda santis and
about the fact that despite being a very
successful governor of Florida at the
moment his presidential campaign is
pretty much floundering he's several
points down on Trump
what do you think's gone wrong for him
well I think he there was a moment uh
towards the end of last year after the
November midterms where Rhonda santis
who just won re-election by a staggering
20 points in Florida which historically
is a very closely contested swing state
between the Democrats and Republicans
um there was a moment and in in those
midterms Trump several high-profile
Trump candidates had failed
um and there was a there was a moment
where the other press were Keen to say
that trumpism was on the Wayne
and that this was the moment for Rhonda
santis who was sort of trump but more
professional less toxic less crazy
um to to emerge and that he could bring
the sort of hard red meat trumpism in
terms of politics and but he was a more
polished performer and he wasn't quite
as unstable As Trump
uh and lots of very rich American
billionaires who fund the Republican
party got quite excited about him they
started donating money towards his
campaign they already had been for a bit
but it accelerated
um and crucially and interestingly
Rupert Murdoch's seemed to like him uh
or there were lots of reports that he
liked him and Fox News became quite
favorable in its coverage towards Ron
DeSantis Fox News is of course the most
powerful media Network in America
uh and um there was this very uh sort of
seemingly iconic front page of the New
York Post again Murdoch's paper which
called him the future uh and it had him
looking quite presidential next to his
very photogenic wife and their britally
dressed children uh and there was a lot
of hype around it really
um and I think having spoken to other
people in Trump World that they were
actually a bit more worried than they
let off right
um they were very vicious about him
there was a lot of cross-pollination
between desantis's campaign his team and
Trump's old people
um and there's a lot of bitterness
between them but then as this year has
gone on and as DeSantis has actually
gone from being someone who everyone
just talked about as a candidate to
actually being a candidate
um it's gone very badly for him and
Trump has just got stronger and stronger
and the key moment of course was this
launch with Elon Musk that seemed very
whiz-bang and clever and techie and
futuristic and it was an enormous Tech
sale inevitably and about several
million people tuned in eventually but
uh most of them were just tuning in to
watch what a car crash it all right yeah
and ever since he hasn't really
recovered and now billionaires are
starting to move away from him and he's
not doing
um so well in the policies now down in
the teens and Trump continues to go from
strength to strength he's now about 30
points ahead in the polls even by the
most modest uh accounts of trump success
so how much of this do you think is down
to De Santa's personal qualities uh I
think you mentioned in his PC sort of
lack of Charisma compared to Trump yes a
a trump campaign Insider told me that
Trump that desantis's campaign is run by
dorks for dorks and I think there's
something in them
um in that he does the sort of anti-woke
thing but he does it rather robotically
he sounds
um uncomfortable he looks uncomfortable
very often in front of people
um he's a bit of an introvert some
people have compared him to Richard
Nixon who obviously was very successful
as a presidential candidate but he is
not
um he doesn't have that sort of trump
wild Charisma I mean almost nobody does
um but he doesn't have a sort of
Charisma that can rival Trump
um and in fact his campaign has sort of
melted upon contact reality because the
key thing about The Campaign which is
him uh isn't selling very well to the
American public it's a very interesting
you mentioned sort of the the anti-woke
campaign it's worked very well for him
as Florida governor do you think sort of
his his success at Governor has kind of
hidden his failings as a campaigner
perhaps I think possibly what he got
wrong in the early stages and I think
he's tried to adapt this a bit is talk
too much about Florida
um he talked about all his successes in
Florida how he you know Florida's a
state where woke goes to die and I think
perhaps he didn't really appreciate that
just talking about Florida doesn't
really speak to a lot of Americans
um and in fact uh a lot of his
popularity in Florida was based on his
closeness to Trump who is a Floridian
resident most of the time uh and is very
loved by that sort of Shifting section
of the of American politics which is
which is embraced trumpism in quite a
big way so you're saying that the wheels
are coming off in large part of this
answer's campaign backers are now sort
of moving away from him
um funding is gonna be a big issue how
much how much do you think that's going
to affect his campaign going forward now
well the the census can't be very clean
over the weekend to cool that he fired
12 staffers over the weekend uh and
there was talks about him sort of
burning up that he's he has raised huge
amounts of money between April and soon
he raised 20 million dollars which is
rivaling Trump
um but he seems to be spending it very
fast and the DeSantis campaign were
talking about a reset and whenever
political campaigns start talking about
resets uh and then desensis himself was
saying he doesn't buy into the doom and
doom and gloom characterization as a
campaign he called it a media a
predetermined media narrative and
whenever people start talking like that
it's sort of a key indication that they
know something's going wrong and they're
trying to change calls quite quickly
reset quite early on in the campaign
I mean some in 2016 had several resets
he changed he fired people a lot
um and you know perhaps that's what
political campaigns need to do is keep
adapting when things aren't working very
well you mentioned as well this answer
has been trying to outflank Trump on the
right a fair bit and bringing up things
like Trump's support for the vaccines uh
support for Trans rights do you get a
sense I was working or is kind of it
doesn't seem to be I mean he on abortion
for instance he's spotted that uh you
know there may be an opportunity with
social conservatives with evangelicals
to be to the right of trump on abortion
but of course Trump can always say I'm
the person who brought you the Supreme
Court that overturned Roe v Wade
and Trump also knows that people don't
really people who vote the largest
sections of the population who vote
don't spend their time obsessing about
not just vaccines or or abortion or
culture wars issues
um they like Brands and they like things
they can recognize and that sounds sort
of patronizing but it's also quite
important
um Trump is a product that sells uh
DeSantis isn't yet and when he talks
about these cultural War issues and when
he talks about social conservative
issues he's speaking to an American
conservative movement which is
very powerful in America and very well
funded and significant in American
politics but it isn't everything and
Trump's base is more than the
conservative movement it's a movement
within itself and so it's very hard for
him to overwhelm that
um you mentioned the piece that it's
well save things it's a long way towards
the primaries now say things don't go
well for DeSantis are there any other
Republican candidates who you think
maybe possibly can challenge Trump or
are now more gonna have more attention
instead of Sean on them because of this
answer's failings uh I think they they
will have more attention Sean on them I
think people are starting to look
towards Tim Scott who is uh
African-American senator from South
Carolina
um similarly Vivek ramaswani who is a
sort of a businessman entrepreneur
turned candidate who speaks very
eloquently and has a lot of sort of
pizzazz but
neither of those two are really going to
pose a significant challenge for Trump
the only thing they can do is do exactly
what the people who want to stop Trump
in the Republican Party have always
dreaded is carry out a reenactment of
2016 in 2024 where different Republican
candidates have sort of highs and lows
but Trump remains uh on top all
throughout and they end up tripping each
other over while trying to get Trump and
they can't coalesce around anyone
DeSantis was supposed to be the
candidate that would clear the field so
that he could take on Trump
um and that so far has not happened if
anything's reverse is happening now
another I mean Mike Pence for instance
who is a disastrous candidate um he's
not getting above six or seven percent
at the weekend
um he was asked about uh you know why
does he care so much about Ukraine when
there's other things going terrible drug
problems crime problems going on in his
country and he said that's not my
concern which is obviously a very very
bad political answer it went viral
instantly but even so Mike Pence because
he's a very well established Republican
name is getting six or seven percent
Nikki Haley similes on a similar number
of a similar level of support and those
people will just draw votes more from
the centers I think than Trump and
they've got no incentive to drop out now
if they sense weakness in the DeSantis
campaign well yeah I think it's too
early for them to drop out uh and unless
DeSantis can have a sort of dramatic
turn of momentum going into Iowa which
is the first caucus's first stage of the
Vulcan nomination cycle on January 15th
um he needs to start changing things
very quickly or we're going to end up
with Trump versus the rebel and in that
case Trump is the inevitable nominee I
think you say one of the other things
that could stop Trump is his current
legal issues I mean what's the state of
play there what's the situation is it
looking likely that he's going to face
a criminal trial for example before the
next election I think um it will it will
dog the whole campaign uh I look for a
while looking might well go to jail for
the rest of his life over the hoarded
classified documents
um that he kept property in his
properties uh at the moment uh that
story has gone quiet and what's very odd
is the way it sort of bubbles up at
strange moments and often perversely and
this is why there's a conspiracy
theories that the Democrats want Trump
in the race so they bring it up whenever
he looks as though he might be fading
because every time he does start to
dominate the news with his legal worries
his Trump his support
ticks up again because people actually
feel sorry for him and they recognize
that this is the politicalization of
Justice which is it's I think that's a
that you can say that objectively almost
I was going to say do you think they're
sort of uh do you think it's a bit of a
nightmare scenario for the Republican
party in that Trump wins the nomination
he's already lost one election before it
gets quite a weak candidate in Joe Biden
that they're going to lose again if he
if he does get the nomination it is a
bit of a nightmare scenario for
Republican Threshers because of the
sheer level of opposition that Trump uh
Wheels out uh just his name is enough to
mobilize a lot of democratic support
Democrats are having a very good time
fundraising for Joe Biden at the moment
largely by talking about Trump because
if you talk about Trump you get a lot of
people pouring money in to stop him
um I think Republicans the ideal
scenario for a lot of Republicans
trashes would be Trump had pulled out
the picture earlier and had and said I
give my full backing to a Ron DeSantis
figure that would have been the ideal
that obviously was never going to happen
and so now Republicans are having to
accept the fact that their movement is
Trump's movement
um and you'll notice that a few people
now fall it back in behind him because
they simply have to brilliant thank you
very much Freddie
and finally spectator contributor Mark
Mason writes in this week's magazine
about the fans who can't bear to watch
sport when he gets too tense England are
currently in a particular tight ashes
series and even some commentators have
said they're covering their eyes in the
crucial moments can you be a real fan
though if you don't watch during the
tough times Mark joins me now
mark thank you for joining us on
spectator TV um especially as we're
filming while the cricket is still on I
know I hope you appreciate this just for
the for all future references as people
watch this over the rest of the match
we're filming this at T on the first day
and England have uh taken pitifully few
wickets on the first day and given the
weather forecasts at Old Trafford it's
not looking that good but still let's um
let's talk about the pieces of the piece
as though the series is still as
exciting as I said it is in the Peaks
well it's very apt that we're doing this
while the cricket is on because you
write this week about the people who
can't watch sports when it gets too much
uh so can you tell us a bit about that
please
well I thought the idea is something
that's bothered me for years and then
the particular uh idea for the piece
came about because of Daniel law cross
one of the TMS commentators on UBC and
at the end of the match last week at
headingley
um he said that if he hadn't been
commentating if he hadn't been
professionally involved in the match he
would have been so nervous by the end of
the match when England were chasing that
he would have been unable to watch and
it's always struck me as strange to make
cricket fans of football fans or
whatever you know when a football team's
a football fans team gets to a big final
Champions League final goes to a penalty
shootout it's the thing you dream of
it's the most exciting bit of sport you
could ever possibly hope to witness and
your team is in that position and what
do you do as the fan that's dreamed of
that for years decades you look away you
go you go out of the rain you turn the
TV off you decide it's too exciting and
you can't watch and I've never
understood it
um and Daniel said it last week and so I
thought right I'm gonna write a piece
about this which is just how crazy it is
and how in effect I'm sort of achieving
them of moral cowardice which is
she's funny I don't want to get too
serious about this but they're moral
cowards uh that they can't they can't
they can't stand the heat they know
the heat is what you dream of as a fan
these are the moments that you've
dreamed of and then why why do you then
especially when you've paid a thought if
you're there at the ground you know
people go and hide at the back of the
stand or cover their eyes
why do you not relish the moment why'd
you have to hide from it I suppose these
people would say they they care so much
that they sort of almost like signaling
that they that they can more than your
average Fanny then I mean did you kind
of buy that uh the sort of caring
signaling rather than virtually or sort
of nervousness signaling rather than
virtue singing well I suppose that could
say that but then I don't think they are
any more nervous it's just that as I say
though one incapable of coping with it
um sorry Daniel if you're watching this
I'm calling you a moral coward
um
it's it's yes I I tell you that point
and but equally you know I I go the
other way I have the opposite I suppose
it's fight or flight isn't it you know
they flee from the the nervousness
um I decide to confront it by watching
and during the 2005 ashes which is the
last series that was anywhere near as
exciting as this
um in fact some people have been saying
this series is even more exciting than
2005. that's how good it is because the
first three matches have been circlipse
uh the I remember doing that series I
was at all of the games on various days
and whether I was watching on TV or I
was at the ground I remember timing my
blinks during the bowlers run
so that I could be sure that my eye was
gonna my eyes were going to be open as
the ball was delivered and the batsman
hit it or didn't or you know whatever
happened that's how Keen I was to watch
that I remember monitoring how much I
was blinking during it again my blinks
out of the way as flintoff's running up
and that made sure that when you know
for instance at edgebroston went
pointing Edge the seventh all of the
over and you know an exciting moment
like that happens that I am watching it
whereas you know people like Norcross
When uh it gets it gets really a squeaky
bump time as Alex Ferguson used to call
it when it gets to that point
they look away I think it's crazy I mean
you mentioned as other people on the
piece who sort of find out the results
and then go back to watch the match
later I mean that seems absolutely
baffling to me
well I said that to Dan when we did I
spoke to him for the piece we said um
I said because he mentioned the time
that he'd done it in 1982. when he was
13 and that's still one of the closest
test match finishes ever England managed
to hang on and to take the wickets that
they needed the Aussies were chasing in
the final Innings and England won by
three runs which is still you know sat
there with education 2005. it's it's
that close
uh but because it was in Australia
during the winter Dan and his father
were staying at um a farmhouse in in
Soviet the Christmas break they were
staying at a farmhouse in Wales and as
it got as the Aussies kept
getting closer to the total and England
weren't quite taking all the wickets yet
Dan and his father decided to go out for
a walk
they put they they put a cassette
recorder by the radio to carry on taping
the radio commentary and then went out
for a walk
as Dan said it's um uh uh that the Sheep
were very confused at these two English
people going out for a walk at midnight
and then they got back so I said to them
well surely when you got back you found
out that England had managed to hang on
and they'd won
then you listen back to the commentary
that you've recorded on your cassette
player it was a C90 down in Roman so he
knew he was only going to get 45 minutes
so uh they knew they were going to
listen back to that 45 minutes of
commentary I said surely it takes away
from the pleasure because you know
what's going to happen and he said no no
it's even more exciting because I know
what's going to happen I know what to
look for if you're watching it back on
TV you know I'm looking for the players
reactions because I know when The
crucial moments are coming
I thought well you know when when do you
go to the cinema do you go and find out
the plot twists in the film you're gonna
about to see so so that you can relish
them all up no you don't so why do you
do that with sport like I keep saying it
makes no sense in these people in moral
cows well Mark I hope you've kept your
cassette recorder running by the TV by
you've been speaking to us um before you
go if you've got any predictions for the
ashes then
oh well I suppose we were guaranteed now
like I say what's gonna happen now that
I'm about to say this is that England
are going to go bang bang bang clatter
of whiskey it's wrapped up the Run
summer managed to get a result of ultra
but assuming that doesn't happen in it
and it you know the Aussies managed to
either get a draw or a win and so
therefore we can't win the ashes at the
oval this is written in the stars
because as of a couple of days ago
somebody saws me a ticket for the
Saturday at the oval so I'm afraid it's
my fault because I'm going the Crooked
gods have decreed that I wasn't going to
get a thrilling series finale to look
forward to but who knows I mean you've
given up trying to predict this series
but if I was going to make a prediction
I would make sure that I carried on
watching so that I could see whether it
came true or not not like these crazy
fans brilliant thank you very much Mark
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]